it's fun to bash pale still middle-class
males for being entitled AF especially
when they make it so easy but privilege
is complicated it's not just black and
white take the current batch of
conservative MPs a bunch of white men so
posh they make Jeeves and Wooster that
like Kevin and Perry so privileged that
the House of Commons is how they
describe literally everyone else's house
but whoever you are if you're watching
this it's 100% that you're packing some
kind of privilege and just like a
carry-on containing oversized liquids
you got to check it take me on paper I'm
a triple threat minority a black queer
women living in post brexit Britain I
get to experience sexism mmm
racism delicious or possibly the sexy
blend that is massagin wha
get you a bigger who can do both plus
nobody really trusts bisexuals so I get
straight-up original homophobia from
straight people by phobia from the queer
community and a whole lot of
well-meaning confusion from my mum Oh my
mum did I mention that she's a first
generation immigrant and that I come
from a single-parent family world's
tiniest violin solo
okay I'm not actually going to shrug it
off and pretend that all that stuff
isn't deep I've been assaulted if he's
in the street and had it assumed by
strangers straight off the bat but I
must love chicken into working which is
awkward because love a bit of jerk and
twerk but unlike a lot of people
including some black queer women I have
got a whole lot of privilege going for
me too
I'm sis meaning my gender identity
matches up with the one I was assigned
at Birth neurotypical which means my
brain basically works the way doctors
expected to able-bodied I speak English
and through being born in London I
bagged a British passport which is
basically a golden ticket so gain entry
to the rest of the globe a lot of why
I'm doing okay today is because I got
lucky in the lottery of life people are
really good at seeing other people's
privilege but tend to be pretty bad at
seeing their own
it's always my poshest friends who say
things like talking about money is so
vulgar
let's just all split the bill I have tap
water and a salad for a reason Florence
I'll split the bill when you chip in to
keep my house also cooling one quality
of privilege does kind of make it sound
like one end of the spectrum is superior
to the other you say black like it's a
bad thing
I love being black I love having lips I
love seasoning I love not being able to
blush it makes me so mysterious so
enigmatic everyone's asking what's her
secret what's she hiding maybe she's
born with it maybe it's melanin we've
got to stop using privilege just as a
stick to beat others with in a start
examining eyes but great privilege comes
great responsibility
you